Nó sức vang ngày hai mấy thứ thống 1 một cho biết, đang theo dõi chặt chẽ tiền truyền cập nhật và tinh trình kè hoạch hòa bình dưới Mỹ vào quay nát tại Gynav Tui C.
Đi phần 1 để gần lý nào đi vì tri pest cóm nói, lấy lời lời bình đe quá quan trọng để có thể bình luật chỉ dựa và chuyên thông.
Tổng thời cho biết nha chưa nhận mào cao chuyên tức nào với cái quả đàn phán.
Ông nhìn mạnh, nha sẽ chỉ đánh giá khi nhận được thông tin qua càng mài giá chuyên tức.
Trước đó, Mỹ và uc quay nát thông bảo đã phát thảo một quân khổ tinh trình và cập nhật sau ngày lạc được độ tiền.
Nhưng chưa còn bủ nội giống, tổng thống của lối đi mê dài lên ski nói kia đăng tìm kiếm các khỏi hiệp của yếu Washington và Châu Âu,
nhằm bảo đàn anh ninh.
Tổng thời khẳng đề bình á phạch chỉ chuyến nhẹp tại chuyến cho trên trang, vùng có việc dùng tại sản nha bị đồng măng.
Để sợ bắt đầu của Mỹ yêu cầu uc quay nát nhiều thêm lạnh thổ, hạch sẽ quân đôi và từ bỏ một kêu gián nhập nát tôi.
Bởi các bạn này, bị giống nước cho ông chỉ trích là thiên nhá khi nó đưa ra và yêu cầu chiên xưa.
Bởi vì nhá tổng thống bất đêm như puti nó ở đây xuất của Washington có thể là nguyên tạng cho một thỏ thất,
nhưng cạnh bảo lúc lượng ngà sẽ tiền xấu hơn nếu kia từ chối.
Lên quan tờ thích những xong đồ các hủ đánh công bằng bài khu ngồi lá của ngà,
rồi thương vong tại khá kép trong khi ngay hàng tưu thương mê một thiệt chưởng thành phố Mác Scuba cho biết,
được lượng phong không đã bàn hạm mấy bài khu ngồi lá của quay nát khi như sân bài tại thủ đô vài tạng dương và đông.